Hey Georgia,
what kind of phone do you have?
>> I have an iPhone.
Why do you ask?
>> Well I'm trying to decide if i should
make Project Compass an iOS app or
an Android app.
And, I don't know how to choose.
>> Well depending on your users,
you may eventually need both.
However, we can evaluate the different
pop forms to see what your next step is.
>> Sounds like a good idea.
There are many things to consider
when deciding between Android and
iOS development such as user base,
revenue models or development speed.
For example, if you want to release
your mobile app immediately,
you may want to start
with an Android app.
Google's app review process
has automated elements, so
you could see your app on the Google
Play Store sooner than you may see
your iOS app published to the app store.
But Android is on
a broader range of devices.
So it may be harder to program for
it because your app may function
differently depending on the device.
iOS apps are only program for
iPhones so there are less hardware
differences to account for.
That's kind of a lot to think about.
There are a lot of factors to evaluate.
But there are also a ton of resources
to help you make this decision.
Okay, thanks Georgia.